Let's go next to Roland from Vienna now.
Is that Vienna, Austria?
Or I know that there are cities and towns
called Vienna in the United States as well.
That's Vienna, Austria.
David Butow from Europe, beautiful, you know,
I if we did not have the virus, I would have
been in Vienna in August and I could be talking
with you right now about my favorite restaurants
in Vienna.
But unfortunately, I didn't go because of
the virus.
Well, listen, mate, I have a second apartment
that I was using to for covid, it was quite
convenient.
Yeah.
So give me a ring on over.
All right.
I will take it you have a king sized bed or
am I going to have to sleep in, like, a bunk?
Separate apartments.
No, no, I know, but does the apartment have
a big bed or a small bed?
Regular people, regular people, the queen
says is American, so it's just adorable.
I love it.
So, listen, I'm from Austria, right, and I'm
watching this.
Well, I was watching it the Safe Harbor Day
now, but 2016 we elected our president.
Yeah, and that got we did a do over because
our right wingers did exactly what you are
doing.
They went to the courts and on.
On, you know, on what he calls official errors,
they they call it the election back and we
had to do a do over.
I'm not familiar with that.
That's that's that's scary.
I still don't think it will have a presidential
election.
And it was funny because we ended up saying
it was the most successful election of the
right wing party.
And we ended up saying, well, they successfully
challenged it.
Yeah.
They successfully challenged their most successful
election and then lost.
So we pulled together, you know.
So is your is your message a message of warning
that it could happen here as well?
A lot of people are saying it's impossible.
I think it is now after Safe Harbor Day.
Yeah, but it has happened in Western civilized
countries and I think this will be important.
This will be the end.
It will be the M.O. going forward for a lot
of right wing crazy parties.
They will just try to steal elections they've
lost.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
I don't disagree.
I have a quick question.
Yes.
Do you think Biden is going to do the full
term, everyone's talking about Trump twenty,
twenty four.
He's going to be a very old man.
I don't even see Biden doing the full term.
In fact, I would be interested.
What do you think the chances are that Biden
hands over after the twenty twenty two midterm
elections to Komala to allow her to be in
the driving seat for her first election?
I mean, again, that would be such a rare event
in presidential history that me saying I think
it's this percent or that percent would be
essentially be meaningless.
I, I, I am aware of the actuarial tables and
life expectancy, and I have a sort of realistic
understanding of the fact that Joe Biden is
78 and Donald Trump would would be that age
or even older if he were to run in twenty
four.
But I wouldn't be able to make any specific
prediction.
But I do expect Joe Biden to serve a full
term.
Great, listen, Dave.
Long time listener, you really I like your
style neutral, but still left leaning.
And, you know, I think everyone knows because
if you look at same Cedar's YouTube account
numbers, he's not even at the one million
mark yet.
That's adorable.
Sorry, that's a little late.
That's a low blow.
That's a.
Thank you.
Well, I'll leave you.
I'll leave you with this low blow.
You know, I also don't think that you need
your your own defense channel, OK?
I think you can show your Zuckoff on your
tremendous Bohner show.
That'll be sufficient for us.
All right, Roland from Vienna.
And Roland, are you pro or anti Salzburg,
Austria?
Is it good there?
Is it nice?
So my parents are there.
It's, you know, very hoity toity.
Oh, it's nice, it's nice.
The rural areas are nice and it's very it's
very condensed, as we say.
Salisbury, Indiana, has the same amount of
tourists, but Salzburg is ten, ten times more
so.
Right.
And then you can you get a can you get a good
cappuccino in Salzburg?
Oh, listen, David, I'm sorry to quote you
here, cappucino, because it's moulage in Austria.
Oh, is that what it's called?
Their Melosh, a Viennese Milosh Vienna is
the home of coffeehouse culture.
Well, listen, I'm going to have to go there
when you're here, please.
Thank you.
All right.
Rollan from Vienna and producer Pat, we will
have to we will have to bleep the F bomb.
That was very, very strongly dropped there.
But he felt very strongly about it.
And so I sort of I sort of understand I guess
I would say